yes so welcome this is phrases rich I
Jamie Fraser built with his bare hands
here we have obviously the bedroom area
very important when I ask a question yes
so when you were building the cabin huh
why didn't you build a separate bedroom
or a toilet yeah yeah it's okay for you
to go behind a tree but you know Jacque
takes a little bit more difficult anyway
moving on we have the kitchen area we
realized that Claire is a really bad
cook this is a little bit of subtext
if you feel look closely whenever I
serve food you may see a slight grimace
on
Longman face this is obviously your
apothecary my apothecary off the caddy
well this is actually something that's
really important to fans who read the
book can you tell us a little bit about
it so this box which is very very
beautiful actually is a gift from Jamie
to Claire and is probably in the top
three things he's ever given her I do
usually right after Rihanna this is a
nice little family this is the aphasia
Jamie made that have you had a lot of
glasses of whiskey on here
yeah well Jamie does indeed have his own
little distillery here and might be
making some moonshine which we will
sample later
fireplace on Jamie's chair which
obviously you are very welcome
this set is absolutely gorgeous when you
guys first walked on to it what was your
initial reaction I'm very good at
building things done how did you do it
yet another amazing job and you know we
do have a few episodes where Jamie's
beginning to build this and it's
remarkable to see you know this one
handiwork it just looks so cool it has
such a different feel to the sets of
previous seasons well and there are so
many gorgeous little details throughout
the set is there something in here
that's your particular favorite mmm my
god above the mantel here I come oh my
god oh my god oh my god thing your
friend that's my gun
I think some of the stuff in the
Apothecary microscope I just those old
brass instruments are so beautiful and
they're also quite a few visitors that
come to Frazier's really there are are
some visitors for people that live in
the wilderness well lastly what is the
one thing that you want fans to know
about Frazier's Ridge before they see it
in season for its beauty represents the
love that it lives within it and you're
all welcome to come on visit yeah
everybody we're gonna Airbnb this
between we all right
[Music]